[Musique]
battus 15 heures de ménage
si quelqu'un s'il connaît dans la région
en chambre à air dérailleur c'est bien
moi raul tabur à la réputation est telle
qu'on ne dit plus un vélo mais un talus
et pourtant
je n'ai jamais su monter ramello
et mon âme c'est que jamais personne ne
m'a cru non bougez pas vous je
m'appelais revêche higuain
notre complicité fut immédiat je ne
savais pas faire de nous étions comme
deux vieux amis d'enfance figo n'y avait
réalisé quelques portraits notable pour
son projet un village des visages on ne
disait plus une photo mais une figue uni
on en fait un tout petit peu plus
fatigué avec de l'éveil il manque un
truc là non toi sur ton beau vélo et 100
dans les pins se plaint dit et ça fait
tellement longtemps
le livre qu'est ce qui t'empêche pas
fait recette y ait connu
[Musique]
tu senti sur les photos ça 21 d'entre
nous dont je voulais pas tuer la faire
ta faute d'accord il ya des instants
comme cela dans la vie
[Musique]
on sait qu'il y aura un avant
et un après année
[Musique]
tous vont enfin comprendre comment ma
vie entière s'est bâtie sur un mensonge
et si c'était aujourd'hui le déclic
jeunes
[Musique]